Daily Show host Trevor Noah continues to
make his mark on late-night comedy he
recently introduced viewers to his
grandmother in his hometown of
Johannesburg to discuss his childhood
under apartheid his grandmother his
grandma said she used to be scared
police would take Noah because he was a
mixed-race and interracial relationships
were illegal why does it give you a
tough time Google we wanted to brave the
street and I knew the flights were not
going to take me so if I was playing in
the street the police would ever
arrested me no shares how his family
kept him hidden in his memoir born a
crime stories from a South African
childhood the New York Times named it
one of the top books of 2016 Trevor Noah
well good morning everyone
oh yeah she was great she was really fun
she still doesn't get what we were doing
no sir any old but and you know what's
great is that she doesn't care that's
what I love so my grand just goes he's
Trevor that's why I like him so I don't
want her to love me to be determined by
what I do or don't do in my world yeah
you couldn't play in the street and so
now you get to play on TV Trevor now
getting serious for a moment what do you
make of what's happening with the
Virginia governor
well let's I mean it's it's an
interesting conversation that I feel
like we need to break down into so many
pieces first of all I think a lot of
people are hurt when you keep getting
reminders of where America has come from
and where America is for many people you
know to see somebody who's in power and
you look back and you go like oh you
were wearing blackface you a part of
this organization even if he says if
that wasn't him he says he wore
blackface from Michael Jackson
competition I think a lot of the time it
reminds people of a conversation that
hasn't been had in America it feels like
that's a conversation around race and
America's past a lot of people say oh
but it's over now it's like yes but you
should love to have the conversations
around it and to his credit Devon often
does say he says he wants to have the
conversations and I think you need to
because like you keep going further and
further down the chain you're gonna find
more and more blackface in Virginia it's
it's not gonna end right yeah it's a we
like to think that we can we can fire a
personal we can get rid of somebody when
we find something like this
but that doesn't solve the problem that
doesn't have a conversation and someone
took that photo of him someone put that
photo in the yearbook someone stood next
to him in that photo someone everyone
was in that community so the larger
conversation is in Virginia what
conversations do they need to be having
around race and everywhere else and I
sang for the record though Trevor that
that wasn't him in the photo and when we
were in Virginia this weekend the driver
who was driving and said you know this
still exists here right this is still
you know we could take you places right
now where people are still dressing up
in blackface and so I think you're right
we've got to have the conversation and I
suppose that's one of the reasons why
you commend Liam Neeson oh yeah and
saying that he profile what I want yeah
what I was saying was I prefer what
happened with Liam Neeson you know one
thing I talk about in my book born of
crime is the the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission South Africa
South Africa is not perfect our system
wasn't perfect one thing I did
appreciate is that I come from a country
where we had to sit down and have
completely truthful conversations about
where the country was and how it came to
be that way and so I think what that
gives you is a certain level of honesty
when having these conversations and so
for me I would rather have it that
people speak and say like Liam Neeson
did hey I had these horrible thoughts
even if it was 40 years ago you know and
it does dig up wounds where many people
will say that's a black person it feels
like an assault you go you realize how
fragile a black life is but it I would
prefer that conversation to be had and
given that history with Truth and
Reconciliation to talk about how you
have to hear things like what Liam
Neeson is saying so he's being honest
right what about on the receiving end of
hearing something like that which to a
lot of people would be you know is when
he gets hammered for being honest
well but here's my thing though if
you're a black person reading that
headline and that's where my problem
comes from a lot of the times the
headline you cannot expect a black
person to have the work now of feeling
bad for Liam Neeson the headline reads
Liam Neeson roamed the streets looking
for a black person to kill I think
sometimes society makes you know puts
the onus on the victims or puts the onus
on those people who have been hurt by
the situation it goes well how do think
about it is think about his position
think about him but if you're a black
person yeah it sounds like and it feels
like that you're living in a world where
your life deadline is always on the line
and
headline doesn't help I know that you're
on the road traveling around the country
you're in Wisconsin Minnesota over the
weekend right does your comedy translate
indifferent does your comedy translate
different ways in different parts of
this country well you know you know
what's funny is when I look at my comedy
when I look at the book one of the
things I realized is stories are
universal yeah right our our figures of
speech are different the way we we speak
our accents are all different you know
you say controversy I say controversy
whatever it is gonna change but but what
I what I've learned and and genuinely
the book has been one of my greatest
gifts there was a there's a kid who came
to one of my shows in st. Paul and
Minneapolis in Minnesota and and he came
and he couldn't come to the show but he
just wanted to come because he had read
the book and this is a young kid who
grew up in America and he said hey your
life reminded me of my life yeah I was
like what how how did you grow up like
like I did and he's like no but there
were so many things that you felt that I
felt I grew up and I see my mom the same
way and my family the same way and so
I've come to learn that if we can find
things that connect us as human beings
you will find that many of us on a
similar journey it's just we focus on
the things that separate us more than
the things that bring us more I like in
the end at the end of the day we can
always readjust your grand 4 question oh
yeah grandmother was hilarious oh thank
you that was a lot of fun and again know
who he was thank you and the paperback
edition of born a crime is on sale
tomorrow